prepare to get your minds blown with I
poppin testimony mr. Govan what I can do
here for you today is tell you what I
heard from people where is the
impeachable offense in that call are
either of you here today to assert there
was an ax people offense in that call
shout it out anyone Congrats Adam Schiff
you found something that made the Muller
hearing look sexy
a witness who witnesses nothing hearsay
based on hearsay a bloated spectacle
designed to turn a phone call into a
crime you know if only we could see this
coming because that tweet is also enough
to impeach the President of the United
States call for the impeachment of the
president Donald Trump has done things
worthy of impeachment impeachment is a
quote real possibility we begin
impeachment proceedings now I guess they
all got the same email from Jeff Zucker
so the guilty verdict comes first which
brings us to this lame-ass show trial
all to gin up public fears about the
next worst thing ever
that never happens because this is never
about what Trump's done but what he
could do this whole thing is a crappy
horror movie scripted by the Dems for
the media with Schiff in his bunch
playing the bug-eyed zombies before a
horror movie to be good we got to
believe it's at least possible and not
already know how it's gonna end
actually this is worse than a horror
film it's pornography for Democrats
remember their safe word that sounds
like a quid pro quo directed by the
president is in fact a quid pro quo to
push for a quid pro quo there was in
fact a quid pro quo be very clear quid
pro quo
that is a quid pro quo no you dopes
that's called leverage and using it on
behalf of your country is Trump's job
especially when he couldn't trust anyone
else to do it every day we heard of
people trying to stop him so what you
expect and how could we have a
presidential candidate whose son is
beholdin to Ukraine and China
Trump didn't investigate that well then
that's impeachable Trump broke no laws
but he may bend the rules a bit because
he has to since the media and the
Democrats write the rulebook which is
why this impeachment spectacle is just a
repeat of the collusion spectacle a
mysterious source triggers a massive
investigation that then goes nowhere
we've seen it we've done it we paid for
it my advice skip it and show up next to
November and give these clowns a hearing
they'll never forget I want to play this
SOT it's a shift talking about the
whistleblower with Jim Jordan it's quite
entertaining
Katie the 435 members of Congress you
are the only member who knows who that
individual is and your staff is the only
staff of any member of Congress has had
a chance to talk with that individual we
would like that opportunity when might
that happen in this proceeding today
first as the gentleman knows that's a
false statement I do not know the
identity of the whistleblower and I'm
determined to make sure that identity is
protected he doesn't know Katie he
doesn't know the second time he's
changed his story right knowing who this
person is so he received this complaint
on August 12th about what the
whistleblower was alleging that his
staff then took it he didn't share it
with his fellow committee members until
the end of September which brought up a
lot of questions about what he was doing
with the whistleblower so he's lying he
knows exactly who this person is but
let's take him at his word for once and
if he says that he doesn't know the
person this is like people need to think
about if we're going to listen to Adam
Schiff and believe what he says is true
then his staff are the ones who have met
this person unelected staffers who are
now running the show on impeachment
based on a claim made that they're
arguing should be used to take the
President of the United States out of
office so if Adam Schiff hasn't you
talked to this person and doesn't know
them hasn't met with them has invited
them to make sure they're legitimate and
that their claims are legitimate then
the staff is doing it for him and so
there should be a little more scrutiny
what about the entire of National
Intelligence Inspector General saying
yeah this is a legitimate issue this
whistleblower complaint should be
forwarded even after the Justice
Department others have I mean so that's
not
you know that's not Democrats I mean
rest of his committee members why didn't
hold on to it for a month and a half
before giving it to the rest of the
committee what I'm saying to you is
first of all the whistleblowers
complaint has been confirmed by
everybody including the two people who
were there today to me that you're safe
you know it's not hearsay but anyway let
me just say I think that the you're
saying this was boring I don't think it
was boring yeah I think in fact if it
was so boring why have we seen that
tremendous movement in the polls over
the last few months we've got the media
94% no it's anti-trump can I get home I
want to get to Jesse no because you've
been talking all day Juan I want to get
Jesse and it looked like Jesse and Jesse
and Katie haven't been talking about
this topic you have been on TV for six
hours oh is that right Jesse I'm gonna
look at this objectively Greg look I
usually do you are the sober analysis
and put my analyst hat on okay now I
think the Democrats did the best they
could do today but it wasn't good enough
it was not a persuasive hearing yeah it
was dense griping by no name diplomats I
respect their service they care a lot
for the country they want to fight off
Russian aggression but to me it looked
like they were complaining about a turf
war over policy and personnel and were
upset that Rudy was stepping on their
toes this was a hearsay hearing these
guys have never met Donald Trump they
weren't on the call and they have
nothing to do with the aid package this
had none of the intensity of the
Cavanaugh hearing not even the intensity
of the Muller hearing where I remember
you remember both of those hearings
where people at work would stop
everything and turn on the TV and you
could hear a pin drop this was not that
so at the end of the day I thought the
Republican cross was strong for the most
part and the Republican base will not
crack and the Republicans in the Senate
will not vote to convict and this whole
charade this is the high-water mark
right now this will all fade as we go
hearing after hearing after hearing wond
sorry you can go ahead and I just wanted
to get him in sit well I love wishful
thinking I think where those marching
orders you were giving the Republican
rank now that
News and out Lestrange well I'm going to
tell you the straight news is if there's
no way it could have gone Jesse from 20
percent supporting impeachment to in the
Fox for every other poll fifty let's
just talk about I'm just telling you
it's gone to the point where if half of
America thinks he should be impeached
and removed that's not your percent of
the media I mean you gotta have some on
your pork I think that these two
witnesses came across as incredibly
credible okay they look I mean a West
Point graduate his whole family a career
dedicated to serving the country glad
you mentioned I would like to actually
say some of the things that these
gentlemen testified to under oath okay
this is the Democrat star witness not a
witness to anything not really a star
but he testified Taylor Taylor met with
the you came president the day after
this perfect phone call and the Ukraine
president told him the witness for the
Democrats that he had no complaints
about the call was a great call and
there were no concerns then Taylor the
Democrat star witness met three times
after that with the Ukraine president
and at no time did the Ukraine president
or anybody bring up any linkage between
the aid and the investigations that
never happened I feel so Taylor
testified that Ukraine didn't even know
the aid was delayed so no quid pro quo
and just for a little cherry on top Juan
Taylor the Democrats star witness said
that the Trump policy on Ukraine was
much better than the Obama policy all
right okay Dana I really have to get me
in I don't mind it's okay but if you
want me to what you want what do I meant
to talk about well okay let's throat a
tale we I think we have a sort of Taylor
talking about overhearing something that
might be fun
Wester Stalin called president from and
told him of his meetings in cave the
member of my staff could hear President
Trump on the phone asking ambassador
Stalin about the investigations the
president's been speaking loud enough
for your staff member to be able to
overhear this it was so this is like
third person removed now it's not it's
from a staff member that overheard it so
people only seized on this because
Taylor did not
this was in his original deposition the
staffer of his said sir I need to tell
you about this because I didn't tell you
about it beforehand so much like
ambassador Sandlin he said I need to
amend and make sure that I have
everything because no I mean I don't
think it's fair to say there's no name I
mean but they don't want they didn't
want to do this yeah they weren't the
whistleblower they weren't the one who
calling for impeachment yeah I think
that they write when Ratliff Ratliff
asked him you know do you are you friend
patient they're both like whoa we didn't
even want to be here in the first place
we had to hire lawyers we had to come
here we're here as witnesses were giving
you our best information they were s are
you against Ron the guy says I'm a
nonpartisan guy Taylor says I am he says
no search the question are you never
Trump so I think that the Republicans
did a pretty good job today on
cross-examination they were I think
sometimes the passion got a little bit
like ahead of them was a little bit
off-putting because they they didn't
actually need to do with that you know
come on so heavy but their point about
that being second hand or third hand
well that will change next week because
unfortunately this is not only going to
happen for one day it's gonna happen for
the next several days and next Wednesday
ambassador Sandlin hit the expectations
for him are going to be super high
because he is somebody who is in first
it has first-hand knowledge I can hardly
wait for that oh boy